are you ready are you sitting down yes
you are how about this one hot off the
presses another shefty bomb the houston
texans have a new quarterback and his
name
is tyrod taylor one year up to 12.5
million speaking of reality it's
possible that nick casario jack eastwood
david cully and company are finally
accepting reality and preparing
what could be a little bit of a
transaction that would involve desean
watson going elsewhere peter
the first thing i hear the first thing i
think when i hear that is
carolina panthers
because you know mike i've thought all
along that carolina has got the best
chance to make this deal
now
they could probably make
uh you know a better deal because it
involves the third pick overall in the
draft
you know because we're obviously talking
about the miami dolphins and tuatanga
veloa
however
i just think that when push comes to
shove
that carolina
and uh and a very aggressive owner and a
willing gm and coach
uh are going to put the most in that
package except except
you know they can't put the third pick
in the first round but they can put the
eighth pick in the first round
and this may be yet another situation
for tyrod taylor where he shows up they
clear out the sean watson and then the
texans draft someone and here comes dr
needle and tyrod taylor loses his job
again right i mean he can't win he
cannot win especially if they would do a
deal with the jets or the dolphins and
get a top three pick or the panthers if
it is the panthers and a top eight pick
that's what the panthers hold we know
the panthers and david tepper they're in
the team very motivated to get a
franchise quarterback the one thing we
don't know about deshaun watson is which
teams he will accept a trade to his
agent has yet to go on the record and
provide a short list of the teams that
watson would play for carolina miami has
always been believed to be the secret
winner there denver which has the ninth
overall pick also could be in play but i
think this tyrod taylor transaction and
up to 12.5
who knows what that means
jameis winston was up to 12.5 and it's
really 5.5 the incentives come if you
play and ty rod taylor may be
understanding there's a good chance he's
going to play that kind of expenditure
tells me he's not being brought in
with the clear cut you're the backup to
desean watts and it feels like the dam
has finally broken peter and the next
move is going to be having an auction
and you suggested a blind auction for
desean watson when we did pft live on
friday some sort of an auction find out
where he'll play take the offers
leverage teams against each other and
maximize your return for desean watson
the reason that the blind auction is the
smartest is it makes you
uh or it makes david tepper to me pay
the most
it makes him sit around a conference
table
and say
hey i know we are we we've already
offered three ones
and teddy bridgewater and whatever i i
know we've already offered this
but
you know
we should consider upping the draft
choice compensation to include a second
second round pick or you know another
third round pick
and the way you do that is if you don't
know what is behind door number two
you are fixing to be behind door number
three but behind door number one and
door number two you don't know what that
is
so a blind auction means that you're
probably gonna pay more than you would
if you were you know going back and
forth
with the texans and and you were trying
to figure out what is the best deal we
can make
here you've got to make probably better
than the best deal you'd like to make
because you're just not sure what other
teams are going to do
well amazing that it's happened and it
really does finally suggest that that
what david cully said to jim trotter and
steve weish in the podcast that dropped
a half hour before the press conference
where he tried to say pay no attention
to that man behind the curtain another
timely reference
that
that comment that he made to washington
trotter is the truth they were just
waiting and biding their time and
preparing to implement a plan so they
get the bird in the hand in tyrod taylor
before they move on and you have to
wonder whether or not washington and
chicago are kicking themselves from
moving as quickly as they did for
fitzpatrick and dalton and oh by the way
not that it would happen we've seen it
happen with players i think it it's
almost impossible to think a team would
do this
but
washington or chicago could say whoa
whoa whoa sorry andy sorry ryan we want
to exhaust this desean watson thing
before we we commit to anything again
theoretically possible but i doubt that
either team would do it becomes very
hard to do business with the agent
community when you start doing things
like that peter
yeah i i don't think
look i mean
let me just ask you this if you're the
chicago bears right now okay
if you're the chicago bears right now if
you're ryan pace right now
there is no question that you have to
before
you know the next 24 hours is up you
have to
make sure that you know nick casario
understands that hey listen we always
wanted to get in this derby we're making
this signing because
we don't necessarily believe that there
was going to be a derby so that's why
we're doing it have you changed your
mind and if so
you know can we get involved
and i i don't think nick casario first
of all there's no way that nick casario
in my opinion is going to be interested
in what the chicago bears have to offer
the same way that
you know there's no way that seattle all
things being equal would be interested
in what chicago had to offer for russell
wilson because the number one thing that
it starts with is the 20th pick in the
draft
you're not answering your quarterback
needs unless you like when you drafted
russell wilson 75th overall in 2012
there's another way down the line guy
uh that that you love and you think is a
long-term starter that's a needle in a
haystack thing tom brady at 199 and
russell wilson at 75 come along once in
a generation so i i doubt sincerely that
happens so i i don't think that we're
going to see
a uh
the bears turning their back on on andy
dalton in this deal
and i agree with you completely peter i
don't think ryan pace and the rest of
the bears brain trust get to the point
where they do the unofficial deal with
andy dalton if they haven't exhausted
every potential avenue making sure
there's no way to get from here to there
as it relates to a russell wilson trade
making sure that desean watson isn't
interested in chicago like wilson had
chicago on his short list making sure
that there's no one else out there you
cross off everyone else before you
settle on andy dalton i mean dalton's
not your plan a per se
he's just your most viable option after
you've explored all others and that's
fine but i agree with you even though
theoretically washington could cut and
run on fitzpatrick and chicago could cut
and run on dalton and get into watson
it would be it would be negligent for
both teams or either team to have made
that commitment without knowing exactly
where they stood on getting watson if
it's something that would cause them to
say holy crap whoa stop the presses and
other timely reference they don't even
have presses anymore stop the presses
we're going after deshaun watson it's
they they those teams knew that was
their best play
dollar for dollar and given the options
and given what they'd have to give up
and given what they could give up i
think you're right that's the key they
don't have the ammunition to make one of
those moves they're not getting back in
and now the question becomes who's
coming to the table for deshaun watson
would it be the jets will it be the
dolphins will it be the panthers who
else is out there that can potentially
could be in play for deshaun watson if
if and
with the texans you never quite know
what the hell they're thinking
but
the the most reasonable interpretation
of what's occurred is deshawn watson
peter now in play your your gut reaction
was panthers mine is dolphins but it's
going to be fun to see what happens and
it could move pretty quickly now that
now that we know that the cat's out of
the bag and the texans seem to be ready
to pivot away from deshaun watson
mike i had thought all along
going back a month or so
i really thought that that they were
going to try to play hardball with him
until after the draft
and
in other words to say look we uh we're
not trading you period no trade no trade
no trade
and
i really think
that what has happened in the
intervening time
is a couple of things i think that there
has become
and which is why i don't think they
should have done anything
uh you know a month ago i think they
needed to see the resolve
uh on you know the part of desean watson
and however that resolve has shown
itself
and we will find out at some point
fairly soon
they clearly have seen that there is
resolve
on the part of uh the desean watson side
but i think the second thing is that
it's easy it's very easy to say for
instance okay we're gonna make you sit
the air okay and mike theoretically
they just signed tyrod taylor to play
quarterback for him
they still could make deshawn watson sit
the ear
they could still stick it to desean
watson you know i doubt they will you
doubt they will
but i just believe that one of the
things if you're actually going to try
to win football games
this year try to win and not have this
sordid gray cloud over your head
of desean watson just sitting out there
you know and people talking about him
all the time okay if you don't want that
then you do have to trade him and the
best time to trade him is now between
now and the draft
i perked up when you said that though
because again one of the biggest
challenges for the rational and i am
willing to consider myself among the
rational some may disagree is to predict
the behaviors of the irrational and one
thing
that the texans have seemed to be for
the past year and it's one year to the
day since they traded deandre hopkins
irrational is what they seem to be so
would it be a stunner based on their
recent behavior
if they would say yeah we just got tyrod
taylor because deshawn watson doesn't
want to play we need a quarterback
desean you can go ahead and sit and if
you decide to stay we'll keep desean
watson with tyrod taylor as his backup
he's used to being a backup he ends up
being a backup everywhere he goes once
the rookie ends up taking over he he's
happy to take up the 12 and a half
million dollars to sit on the bench so i
i don't think that's as small of a blip
on the edge of the radar screen as you
do because i just can't predict what the
texans are going to do because they're
so damn unpredictable and i don't think
it's intentional
i don't think it's small i don't think
it's impossible
i think it's very possible i i wouldn't
say it's likely
but you know on a scale of one to ten
how could that happen
yeah i think it's two or three
but but i think
at the end of the day
okay
nick casario
is a competitive person
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports